[Musique]
je dois filer à la caserne du retourne à
l'hôpital je garde ce soir on se voit
plus tard
suis toujours inquiète de devoir partir
s'entraîner claire lannes urgence radio
team vient d'être déclaré
[Musique]
si l'on n'intervient pas tout de suite
au coeur du réacteur
ce n'est pas la population locale ou
même kiev que l'on risque de contaminer
c'est toute l'europe
on est au bord du gouffre la population
n'a pas besoin de savoir on risquerait
de provoquer l'hystérie générale
concentrez-vous sur le réacteur no
charge de la politique
les volontaires seront récompensés vous
ne comprenez pas c'est une mission
suicide a les hommes que vous allez
envoyer n'ont jamais été formés à ça ces
terres de mourir alex je te promets
qu'on va s'en sortir
[Musique]
ça fait quoi le respire eux
jamais on sortira de cet enfer
[Musique]